[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
by the way the ayahuasca t-shirt
ayahuasca is for lovers is for sale
danpatrick.com
the t-shirt that everybody wants because
apparently ayahuasca made aaron rodgers
a better lover
somehow we make the smooth segue to
darius rucker who joins us now
you know i was thinking about you when i
heard this aaron rodgers story about
ayahuasca when you guys were thinking
about me yeah well no no hold on
because when you guys were
doing a show you guys were upstate new
york
and i think some mushrooms were consumed
yeah
that was a great story okay yeah we were
playing on the ph
and after the show they were consumed
and uh we pretty much went up and lived
a life up in the hills
of state new york for about six hours so
wait you just you guys just went in the
woods and got lost we just went in the
woods
some people were the highlanders because
they went high in the woods
full intro darius is the headliner for
the next cmt storytellers one hour
concert special featuring performances
never before heard stories about how
some of the star's biggest hits came to
life a three-time grammy winner and of
course uh the uh former lead singer of
hootie and the blowfish all right here's
the poll question would you rather be
you still the lead singer
you are still the lead singer of
blowfish okay so still the current
lead singer
until you're replaced yes you know
i'm thinking
scott stapp
of creed will take
over i think they're gonna get corey
glover from living color
[Laughter]
um okay here's the poll question today
would you rather be you
or nick saban
like whose career oh nick saban
nick saban okay next seven [ __ ]
everybody wants to be the goat you know
everybody's supposed to be the greatest
of what they did nick saban is now in
that michael jordan ric flair
uh category tiger woods being the
greatest at what he's ever but what he
did everybody i'd rather be nick okay
but if i said you could be george
straight
or you could be nick saban
oh george straight
yeah
[Laughter]
we saw this uh documentary on woodstock
99 i don't know if you've seen that yet
i saw some of it i'd see the whole thing
but yeah it's
were you asked to be at
woodstock night was hoodie in the below
man
we are cool enough to get asked to do
stuff like that you know
wait a minute what you had atlantis more
said and sure
but
we've never been invited to bonnaroo man
really
yeah
if you were invited to woodstock 99
would hootie and the blowfish have gone
of course absolutely
but you know what's tricky though
is where they place you
let's say corn is playing and then
hootie in the blue rage against machine
is playing and then hootie in the
blueprint comes up
let me tell you right now if they put
rage against machines in front of us we
just go pack up and go
but you know who they followed
up do you know who they followed rage in
the machine with
bruce
hornsby oh my goodness
who the hell is thinking
i'm sure that was that was fun yeah wow
yeah that's a good idea okay you know
who followed corn
who jewel
okay
all right
whoever whoever put that show together
was not was really high
but have you have you been at a festival
where
when you come on or
like you know you know the audience is
like oh boy i don't know if this is
going to go well
uh
not so much a festival
um
i was at a guitar pool once
and
[Music]
chris stapleton sang before me
and i was like i'm not singing
[Laughter]
if you don't if you don't move my butt
my partner's show i'm not thinking of
myself
[Laughter]
why would they not have chris stapleton
close it out
that's what i asked the same question
they were like well you got the heads i
was like yeah but do you hear this boy's
voice
uh the last time you were nervous going
on stage i get nervous every night i
still get nervous every night
because it's
you know some nights are better than
others and i think if i ever stop
getting at least a little nervous i'll
stop playing
but are you
are you nervous you're going to forget
words
no i was more nervous
you know you're more nervous you're
going to miss notes
i'm 56 now i got a teleprompter so i'm
not so worried about the world
but it's more like you know hitting bad
notes and stuff yeah that's more worried
about that than anything else wait you
have to read off a prompter
no i never do but just in case i have to
uh you know if i've you know i have
forgotten you've seen me forget through
i turned to you door and let her cry and
go hey dan what's the word i know you've
seen it happen so
so darius is out there singing and then
he turns to me at the side of the stage
he goes what are the one of the words i
go you wrote the damn song not me
letter and it was letter cry i played it
eighteen hundred times i didn't know the
words that's unbelievable
you ever had a crowd though that was
dangerous
oh yeah oh yeah we've uh well you know
back in the club days big time but uh
uh one one day we were playing the crazy
thing is we played so many southern
places enough and it's everything's been
okay and we play in upstate new york
once the country show
and we look out and there is
five confederate flags that are bigger
than my bus
and these guys are walking around the
crowd oh boy with them and so my guys go
out and go and they admit who they were
and what they were there for and we
kicked them out but we thought we're
gonna have to fight those guys yeah
how do you perform when you look out you
see that
well i performed for everybody else but
then you know i'm still sitting for the
people who paid their money you know
oh man
jerk's gonna be jerk's gonna be jerks
man they're gonna do it i can't let that
mess up everybody else's club
uh fritzy has been singing lately
he did always great
no no
no
okay so olivia newton john just passed
away
yes yes and uh fritzy did a tribute to
olivia newton john
but he oh that's awesome no it's not he
so he he wanted to sing a song that was
let's get quizzical instead of let's get
physical so let's get quizzical when we
have a quiz about sports
so uh you judge it and maybe maybe i'm
wrong maybe maybe there's magic in here
and uh here's here's todd singing let's
get quizzical we're coming up with
questions that i know you like it makes
good sports radio conversation
you gotta answer it just right you know
what i mean don't google it just try to
think it out challenge yourself mentally
make sure you know what you're talking
about or get embarrassed on radio and tv
let's get quizzical
did you you look like you just ate bad
fish
i'm like didn't was he even listening to
the music
to the music that was not your best
christy pritzy that was not your best
friend
and you know there is
he was trying to pay tribute to her he
wasn't joking he was oh i know that was
bad that and you know i usually like
your stuff that one was bad has anybody
said no to you covering one of their
songs
no but you don't have to ask you know
you just play them
even when you record
you don't have to ask just record it
and then you never ask anybody yeah and
then they get paid yeah
so when ryan adams did the entire taylor
swift album
he doesn't have to ask taylor swift
i mean no he doesn't have to i mean i'm
sure he talked to her about it but he
didn't have to not by law no
what's the song you wasn't you want to
cover but you haven't been able to
oh good question uh you know what song i
really think i'm gonna get zach brown i
mean z and jack brown are gonna do pink
houses that that's my goal i think that
would be a really good song to do with
that
okay yeah maybe a caller for me have you
talked but but you've done the song with
john mellencamp
yes we did a crossroads and it was it
was one of the great moments of my
career that was awesome
but didn't melanchem say hey i know it
was a big deal for him like he was
just another day
[Laughter]
i mean it was really
that's not one of those things that
crossroads is not something that he
would do a lot for him to say he would
do with me was a big honor but you know
yeah john i was just no i'm i'm you know
pooping my pants and you know john just
like get this rehearsal over with
um how were you when you thought the
dolphins could get tom brady
i was i don't want to already i want i
want to talk a little bit oh okay
you're all in huh
i'm all in
god we got the cheetah we got waddle
i i i have already the nfl called me the
other day asked me my ring size for my
super bowl ring
do you think that the nfl
is it time for the nfl to give halftime
show to country music yeah i think it's
time for a country i think it's time for
i mean it hasn't been a country since
singer since garth did it back in the
day so you know we've had some great
ones i think it's time to okay i'm gonna
make you
you're producing it give me give me five
acts
for arizona super bowl
uh
luke ryan
uh
blake shelton carrie underwood
[Laughter]
oh you wouldn't want to say garth
mcgowan has already done it so you know
you ended with george strait just
standing up there behind that microphone
do it give it away or something and
you just got heaven right there and once
again your bias against chris stapleton
showed because you didn't mention chris
stapleton well that's because i don't
want to have to sing after him
what about taylor swift
oh but taylor's pop now taylor's going
to get her own super bowl by herself why
does she have to come in hours
okay we have ours can we just have our
little thing kayla's gonna have her own
big super bowl all right so you're in
you're in um
there's nothing i want there's nothing
in the world i want to do more than
in my career there's nothing i've done
there's nothing i haven't done but half
time in the super bowl that i want to do
nothing
that's it
huh all right
well you you know you got some good
artists there carrie underwood's you've
sang with carrie underwood haven't you
absolutely very special she's one of the
best singers ever she's special
what's special what's more likely to
happen you're half time at the super
bowl or the dolphins are in the super
bowl
dolphins are in the super bowl
[Laughter]
uh so we're going to see you in a couple
of weeks
looking forward to it man always looking
forward to seeing yeah that will be in
my back bridgeport connecticut yep and
by the way what
dolphins are going to win the super bowl
you i'm and this is not the darius
pre-season prediction crazy stuff you
say this every year
but this is our this is my nostradamus
year this is the year
you will be playing this in february
okay but like let's make a bet on this
because you just throw this out every
year and i never call you on it
okay what do you what do you want to
stop are you telling me i'm confident
fritzi gets to sing
as the opening act
on the road with you
i'll do this if they don't go fritzy
gets to pick any two songs he wants my
band will learn him and he gets to come
up and sing absolutely
but what if he wants hallow notes like
they'll don't know it don't know it like
we'll know it like we wrote it
absolutely that's amazing
are you okay with that time i am all in
on that that's i already got private
eyes and kiss on my list working so so
so you're not gonna play darius songs or
hootie songs you're gonna do haul and
notes you play with awards you're
playing
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
sounds like a lot of fun uh
what does darius get if he wins
absolutely what what yeah paul if darius
wins i get to come i get the cover
yeah
i'll let you host the show what what
paul if i do if darius wins
i don't want that i don't want that no i
won't make that bad because i want
pretty to keep singing and you don't
want to host this is three hours man
like this is this is a lot
i could do three hours man
once i don't want to do it like
everything
all right that's fine
um all right we got it
all right uh yeah all right i'll see you
in a couple of weeks
all right man i love you all right love
you too that's uh darius rucker dolphins
make him cry not this year though
not crying super bowl or bus yeah i like
it